[Music]
eight years ago I started as a beauty
blogger I took a leap of faith and ended
up starting my own makeup line called
fini beauty hey everyone welcome back to
entertainment tonight I'm your host
Kristen Gill and today we have Hooda
Katan here she some of you may know her
as huda beauty online she boasts over 25
million Instagram followers insane she's
not only a talented makeup artist she's
also a wife a mom and a beauty boss and
now you have your own Facebook watch
series I love that kind of play on words
like hooter Bob it's a play on words I
think people don't really know some
people think it's just hood a boss but
no it's actually like who is the boss
there's so many people who's running the
show I don't know I've never felt so
much pressure in my life this is not
gonna go out but the goal is to make us
the number one beauty brand in the world
so tell fans about what they can expect
from the new show you know when we had
decide to do a show we weren't really
completely sure first of all you know
what kind of angle we want to go do you
want to go more family do you want to go
more business and we thought it made
more sense to be more kind of you know I
think oriented towards the business but
also it's still showing the family
dynamic so we wanted to keep it really
raw really real yeah and and I think you
kind of see that I could you kind of see
like you know it's a juggle but doing
the two you inspire so many women you
and your brand is about just wanting you
know people to feel like they can be
beautiful yeah matter what yeah race
what gender definitely you come from a
Middle Eastern background yeah I'm sure
you know how many women in the Middle
East you inspire and thank you the
barriers you've broken down as a female
yeah what does that mean to you it's
really hard starting out actually and
giving a female being in the Middle East
I think you know fortunately Dubai is
much more open than other parts of the
Middle East but you know I was
definitely I had to jump some hurdles
and you knows treated a lot sometimes
that it was like a hobby and it wasn't a
business to be taken seriously I had a
lot of men who when I first started in
no shape to men because there's amazing
man who won empower women but I had
some really big businessmen who wanted
to come in and kind of dangle a carrot
in front of me and try to you know take
advantage of our company and where we
were and the fact that we needed money
in the beginning and we held out we were
bosses about it your family kind of
reminds me I don't I'm sure you get this
person all the time - yeah how do you
feel about being compared to them I
think for me outside of me appear that
way yes you know I do think Kim looks
very middle-eastern if you go to the
Middle East
a lot of women look like her they aren't
she's beautiful it's not anything that I
necessarily I don't get upset about but
of course you want to be your own person
yeah and I think I'm the outside it may
be here that way but we're definitely
you know we're dysfunctional in our own
way are you sure yes because I passed
that I didn't see okay never feeling
everybody honey flavor of dysfunction
and we're our own favorite you said that
you did Royals in Dubai yes their makeup
yes what did you think about mega Marcos
wedding makeup I loved her so much I
actually loved her I don't think I've
ever been a fan of any royal wedding
didn't look this way I mean it's just
been so beautiful to see her you know
breaks and breaking those barriers yes
yeah she and her makeup was beautiful I
was so light it was just I I felt like a
little it was a little unexpected mm-hmm
you know I expected a little bit more
glam and she was just like nope this is
me this is me and my glory and I'm
beautiful I don't need it so much and I
just loved it she's so beautiful I know
I'm sorry
thank you so much for being here who
don't you so tell everyone where they
can watch your show so they can watch it
every Tuesday night at 6:00 p.m. on
Pacific Center time on Facebook what
tune in guys
you